[sirens]
DISPATCHER 1: There's
a reported structure
fire for [inaudible] 64.
DISPATCHER 2: We think
it's a pretty heavy
flack on Adams above Holbart.
DISPATCHER 3: --checking out.
We've got bottles
through the window.
DISPATCHER 2:
[inaudible] in that area.
[inaudible]
We have a fireman shot.
We need help immediately.
DISPATCHER 4: Roger.
We can't make it down
in front with a gurney.
DISPATCHER 5: They're
dispatching LAPD units
along with all fire trucks
that respond to major emergency
blazes for our protection.
But with respect
to trying to get
LAPD service or anything else,
folks, you're on your own
down there.
[sirens]
[music playing]
NEWSCASTER: There
are fires burning.
There are people being beaten.
There is looting.
It is a dangerous night in
the city of Los Angeles.
[sirens]
PETE WILSON: I'm advised
that there is someone
from the Secretary of
State's office on the way
over to accept this proclamation
of a state of emergency
for Los Angeles City
and Los Angeles County.
This is in response to
requests by Mayor Bradley.
As a result of the
discussions that we have had,
there will be as many as 750
California highway patrolmen.
Additionally, we have
made available some 2,000
National Guardsmen.
They are on standby
prepared to move.
Transport has been arranged.
And it is our purpose here
at the state government level
to restore law and order
and to minimize the danger
to the residents of the area.
This is a matter that needs
to be settled in the courts
and not in the streets.
Thank you.